congratulations I mean what a journey
you have been on how are you feeling
heading into the Grammys I mean you know
it is I mean a lot of no I've made films
and they've all had extraordinary
Journeys nothing comes close to the
Elvis Journey forget the discovery of
Austin forget the pandemic that I'm
going away to get even the recent like
unimaginable sadness that we that
everyone in the film has gone through
with the loss of Lisa Marie and then you
have a high of the nominations for Oscar
and then tomorrow's a Grammys and we're
up for you know best soundtrack and all
of that you have so much going on so
many happy things but also a very sad
loss that you guys have all experienced
how are you doing I mean I feel
however I'm doing
it's of no comparison to how the family
is and what is so extraordinary is
through the film we all became so close
and so embraced and I can only every day
I think actually amount the rest of the
family and about how are they doing you
know
um and yet we we have to march on we we
have the Grammys we have the Oscars so
it's like a roller coaster of emotions
it really is roller coaster of emotions
but you guys have done such a beautiful
job of making sure you honor the family
and now even more you have that
that loss that you can honor in a
special way now moving no I think I mean
if well you said what do we do well the
one thing that Lisa Marie was so happy
about was that her father was somewhat
put back through the film in the right
place in the hearts of people around the
world and a whole new audience and and
so that's maybe one thing that is in the
right place does it bring you comfort to
know that she is now with her father I
mean I saw a sort of painting like that
today someone did a painting like that
said
we were coming home and you know what
whatever your own particular beliefs are
the The Poetry of that idea is beautiful
you know the PO I want to believe that
that she has come home I want to believe
that will we see you on Sunday at the
Grammys with Austin yeah I I don't ever
ask a mate he's gonna be in London and
if he gets back but I I'll be there and
Dojo will be there she's definitely
gonna mean
we love the Doge
[Music]
foreign